and we are live see I had to say the
live part that's the only part I needed
to do Laura's podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet and I called Negros very
specific that Lords a gaming dotnet
needed to be in the intro so I got that
took and go this is episode 133 as you
can see we are missing the host of the
podcast Lord kognito he had to go
deliver some packages around the world
and reconnect the United States of
America he you'll probably jump in later
on in the topics if he has time I don't
really know but you know safe travels to
Laura kognito so you know without Laura
kognito here today I'll be your host
Lord Ashton
I have addict I'm addict fide IOP today
I dig define identified no it's catified
okay this is I'm the host I say create I
want to sing amigo words I'm at on
Canyon we have we have an amazing show
for you guys later today we'll start the
show with some death stranding because
actually some people actually played
that game now I keep forgetting the game
just came out you know we've been
talking a lot about a game that has it
came out but that society addict
you don't played us trending you live
then we have some game past at some game
past news or not really news but stuff
that King had to get off his chest so
we're gonna play and get that down the
road and then after that we're gonna
talk about some leadership changes at
Sony and then we're gonna end it with XO
2019 predictions so we're here we're
joined by friend of the realm a
supporter of the Lords a person without
question I would share the title of
difficult gang conquer with it has some
of the most useful and straight to the
point on how to videos introducing the
person responsible for the yikes
movement lady a that inch I was worried
you weren't gonna come with it what's
funny is I watched the old one and I had
to put the ice and I was like Cod deed
already addressed the yikes but I don't
care it needs to be in there now if you
want to go see them you know all the
premium gyms and stuff that Lord kognito
did her
you know that was originally took place
on episode 96 so you definitely go do
that now you know I'm not the biggest
fan I'm gonna give the mic to to lower
King David so he can do his combat song
wow this is the worst introductions - hi
everyone by the way I didn't really get
to say that oh wow
addict we are ship without a rudder look
I need a shout out to the rudder that's
out there delivering packages deaf
standing style um last night I hope you
guys got a chance to see you know cuz
I'm my um subscriber to the zone the
zone is a sports app that is trying to
challenge ESPN I know it's kind of hard
and Showtime and HBO but they're putting
out compelling content and they're
giving you 50 fights per month if it's
our Bellator if it's boxing you got
boxing on Tuesdays Thursdays Fridays
Bellator on Wednesdays Saturdays and
Sundays I believe and last night we had
Logan Paul versus Cass I or case I
versus Logan Paul depending on how you
who you follow and I'm leading up to the
fight I was interested I was watching
there did little 40 days into the fight
and it got to a point where I said you
know what I'm gonna give these guys a
shot the first fight was pretty
entertaining to me so this fight it was
the debut of them this time they didn't
have headgear on this time this fight
was considered their first pro fight
alright
they SPAC tout the day to pack that in
the Staples Center they sold the whole
place out I think that's like 12,000
people was youtubers from around the
world shot up - every youtuber every
content creator the whole card was
filled with you
tubers the arena was filled with
youtubers it was a movement that I was
very proud at seeing with saying that
any youtuber out there I want to fight
me let's do it I'm gonna talk to Eddie
her to get this done but I saw two guys
lay it on the line now if you want to go
by who actually won the fight I would
say Logan Paul I wanna fight if you're
going by the rules of the fight he got
penalized two points I thought the ref
was overzealous when he penalized him I
don't think the ref knew it was only a
six round fight because if it's a six
fine fight you just reprimand the guy
and put him back in there um or if it's
so egregious that you just give him one
point the reason why he deducted a point
was he punched um ksi or a winner
uppercut and as cascais was going down
he grabbed his head hit him again with
another uppercut and as he was on his
knees he punched him in the back of his
head while he was on the floor um these
are not professional fighters they're
learning these amateur mistakes that
they were making and I mean a strong
stern warning would have been my
preferred cup of tea but he didn't give
him that he took two points away from
the man in a six round fight understand
you know at that point in time dude is
done all right so either he has to knock
out ksi and kiss I was leaving his heart
and soul out there so ksi gets to win
and I think it sets up a third fight but
um the interviewer yeah it was like a
celebrity exhibition match this was
really for real anybody's reflected the
level of seriousness that they took
going in because Logan Paul look ripped
and right ksi legume and he was athletic
and they were moving it's just it's just
a moment for you guys to understand that
everything is possible um these are
youtubers these are guys that were doing
some form of content and they used that
platform to do whatever they dream was
and it guided them to someplace else
so you know I hope y'all got a chance to
watch it if you don't get a chance to go
on youtube we'll check it out and see
how you know it he gave you a different
graphic it was a a younger crowd
everybody was into it it was totally
different from like an MMA crowd or a
boxing crowd Justin Bieber was there I
was a YouTube exclusive no it was it was
just to see it it was elating because it
showed you there's a whole different
lane for this you know it was just a
bunch of young people having the time of
their life you know you all these guys
like it was so many different youtubers
there I had to have somebody to point
out and tell me exactly who's who and
what was usually a lot of times like you
see the panel guys not one has they face
right so a lot of times you don't know
who's who and until somebody actually
tells you all that such and such and
that such and such and it was like a
who's who of YouTube was there and it
was fantastic it was just a really
entertainment thing if you got a chance
to see it um I talked about it on
Twitter you really had a really good
time it was there it was really fun you
know the boxing matches the actual
because I had actual fighters that was a
little bit boring compared to the
youtubers that were fighting you know
I've noticed cuz there's a lot of
amateur stuff here and I'm sure people
really go at it because they really know
how to fight dokie silly get those they
either a can't can't risk late arms up
anymore they can't lift their arms up
anymore or someone gets knocked out
yes you know I'm sorry I was just gonna
say I I saw a comparison picture for I
think it was Logan Paul yeah it was him
and he definitely beefed up for this
fight you saw his body right yeah like
they took it serious very serious I'm
just like it is so fantastic to see it
and understand the humble beginnings to
where they were they were talking trash
on internet they gave it up to each
other at the end you know they shook
hands as a man it was like it's a
different level of spec respect when you
do this um the dance had death in the
ring with a person especially if you do
it twice and you do for real there's a
different level of respect that you have
for somebody after
you really have to do some long hard
rounds with that person it was it was
very nice to see I think it brought a
community a little bit closer than in an
audience to get a chance to see or
combat sports it's about so plus you
capitalize on that the general the
amount of people that's on YouTube in
general you you introduce a lot of
people to boxing in general yeah I
remember too cuz they can go into MMA
after this I would have loved to see him
in MMA I sort of got I would have loved
this even throwing kicks so just to be
clear yes
it's all good well I mean we're gonna be
talking about it been playing that death
stranding so I got some thoughts on that
once we get to it what else the neo to
beta
yeah it's about to end to it it was for
10 days so I think it's coming up on
like the last day and I actually have
intros for the Lords but see Lord King
he brought up combats board before the
podcast I wanted to make sure he got
that so of course we have the other
Lords here we have the Lord that helps
me shut down all positivity on the
switch the person we call well we need
something thrown in the bushes the one
and only Lord King how you doing
fantastic as you said throw it in the
woods just throw any wishes in stores
today I got a t-shirt as long as
especially filled Dominus Maximus
pension is in there go get those and we
have some other stuff that's cooking up
for you guys um like I said last night I
was watching a fight on what I've been
playing ukulele um I got a chance well
you know destiny I finally got that gun
I did their little mini raid where type
of dungeon thing it was pretty fun I
liked the content that they're pushing
now destiny seems like it's on a roll I
think it's in a good place right now yes
it fills in pocket it feels nice
I'm actually considering using real
money to buy stuff from the ornament
store because it feels like I'm
rewarding the team for what they're
doing because the level of content we
had I am banner going on with momentum
with that raid little mini red layer
thing to get an exotic gun well along
with another raid quest and no point in
time with their life with Activision
where we able to get all three things at
one time and still festival of the Lost
is going on right now
it's amazing the podcast I'll probably
jump back on that me too and obviously
you know what you've been playing King
oh that right there and it was one game
oh sorry guys I want to get Luigi
Mansion right now financially and
collective wise I'm not into collecting
games and let him catch dust you know
I'm mad that I got Zelda and I didn't
get a chance to give it as just do um
game pass is really going crazy right
now so what I'm trying to do is trying
to get through games and then I'm be on
to the next game so I'm not gonna um you
know get another game just let it sit
there collect us Black Friday come
around and I could probably pick up
Luigi Mansour's then but I really want
that game because it looks great I drop
Zoda
I dropped it quick and then obviously
you know we do have another Lord here we
had the Lord that helps me I could just
read the same thing at it we have the
one and true ally of Lord Cognito
the the knight of the switch gang
movement and the king of playing games
at ignoring Lord addicts party invites
how you doing Lord
[Laughter]
he and the bushes are the bushes right
now um but it's okay out of a podcast
he totally dropped out is running wild
yeah I don't know where yeah I don't
ignore you at it just you know I did
meet you that's the difference I see you
you know what's going on nothing watch
what you've been playing if you complain
the death stranding yeah I didn't get to
watch box and I didn't get to do
anything cuz you know what I was doing I
was walking and pooping and then walking
and delivering can't forget that part
oh yeah before we get to the top let's
get let's get last week's poll I was
originally gonna drop this but you know
I felt like it was tradition that we
needed to do it so last week's poll went
through and the people have spoken I
think that's how low kognito says is I'm
pretty sure with the mostly positive
views of deaths training before release
do you think it's possible for a game to
be not fun slash boring yet still get
high rated because of its narrative and
with the majority of 53% they agree it's
the Kojima effect that you know there's
a little bit of that bias going towards
his name with the 53% I am NOT Laura
Cognito I was not going through the
other ones that is the winner will
continue you know death strannix finally
out you know we've talked about this
game for a long time you know people
actually have their hands on this game
now and lord Erica and Lord sovereign
has it so I'm gonna go ahead and let
solver and talk about you know what's
going on with DES stranding Lord
sovereign um it'd be like that sometimes
can I tell you man after all the
commentary last week all the speculation
about what it is and what it is and and
hearing other people's takes on it they
have played it obviously you know you
know us we have to play it we have to
play it really figure out if this is
what it is and I have to say that the
vast majority of takes that I that I got
from it last week
kind of still holds true this is very
much and let me say the positives right
the game is gorgeous the game is
absolutely it takes that decimal engine
to another level that you want to see
Norman Reedus on your TV you there
forget about walking dead just turn his
eyes Norman Reedus its Norman Reedus
with some muscles right because I heard
that he better keep better got like a
dirty pack man that man carry a building
on his back I see I've seen the stuff
use carry and be taller than him oh yeah
absolutely it gets too ridiculous
Heights it's kind of funny um well yeah
honestly man everything we heard about
it so the story is basically that
there's been this cataclysmic world
killing event that has made the
decimated the entire world but at the
same time what has done is created this
sort of rift between the living and the
dead and so the death stranding
literally is that the dead or or spirits
or ghosts are sort of caught in between
their world and ours so there's
literally stranded in our in our plane
of existence and your job is to try to
reconnect the world by delivering
packages and getting light likes for
delivering packages it is the premise I
think they could have done so much more
with it action wise I know
I heard that there's some more action
stuff later on in the game what I played
thus far is just super boring
it really is taking packages getting
them from one place to another avoiding
BTS in the process and trying to balance
your way there because the big mechanic
of the game as you're traversing is
keeping your balance not falling over
not damaging the packages as much as
possible as you go from point A to B so
what happens is the Kojima tries to
gamify like very menial small things
that you don't need to gamify like in
terms of climbing and stuff like that
and what happens is it makes the
mechanics boring and
they're pretty much broken
because basically you can lose your
balance depending on how much stuff you
have on your back right so what you have
some fun commands to constantly but this
is the thing you can do that right and
constantly it just left him right with
the l2 and r2 right and have this funny
little balancing act where you're just
swaying back and forth or you can just
cheat and hold them down the entire time
and you're constantly gonna be more are
you serious yes I do that's what I do I
do do that yeah you can literally break
the game and just hold it down and you
won't lose your balance so he didn't
design around people just holding the
buns in I think there is an easy easy
mode for what I read it doesn't
necessarily change the way it like
encounters gold with BTS and stuff like
that it is it I think it has to do with
like the terrain traversal like because
when you're traversing the terrain you
have this up this sensor that you can
kind of you can kind of press a button
it'll show you the terrain and it's it's
graded in terms of how difficult it is
to traverse like from green to yellow to
red red being very difficult steep steep
terrain stuff like that yellow being
medium stuff like that and the same
applies to like bodies of water and
things like that so I think it maybe has
something to do with that but apart from
that I heard everything else just kind
of been taxed was not really an easy
mode so what is terms of difficulty is
it's not hard it's just it's just
tedious and kind of boring at least to
this point
boring boring kind of boring ending it
you guys get on me for loving red dead
but the red dead world is vibrant is
alive like this stuff to do in that
world like you run around and kill
people and cause havoc this is not that
this is literally a barren wasteland
where you're just going from A to B
you'll run into some some enemies every
now and again you'll do the BT thing
where so when you're going through a BT
area like be T's basically look from
what I've seen so far they basically
look kind of like Frieza from Oh
I have these like long tails and
whatever you the way you get through a
BT infested area is that you use the
baby to sort of and your sensor sort of
gives you an idea of where they are and
you basically try to traverse through
them crouched as slowly as possible and
often if they see you they're gonna try
to grab you and pull you down - they're
- they're like this nether region and
you can try to fight them off or if you
get pulled down there there's there's
some there's a thing that you do that
you come back up or whatever Sam never
really dies oh and that's pretty much it
I don't know later on this there are
some things where you can fight them and
I believe you can kill them
so I I don't know if I'm gonna get to
that point I'm gonna be perfectly honest
with you I dropped it I might
I don't know I'm I'm nuts like that I
may just try to see it through but it's
right now it's tough going
one thing that surprisingly that I know
I won't say that I enjoyed the story is
weird but it isn't confusing weird like
I kind of got everything they're trying
to say it's stupid and korn Ian and and
weird but it isn't this crazy
multi-layered thing at least not yet
that's not understandable and nuts and I
have to say like the acting the actors
are all in like they really are no the
only person that feels like he's sort of
phoning it in is maybe Norman Reedus and
that that's Norman Reedus and everything
I have been to almost the the little bit
of positivity I have heard has been you
know the way the game looks apparently
it's a very gorgeous game in the way
that the acting is apparently it's it's
top-notch it definitely is I give it
that but everything else around it
everything else that makes it a game and
I know we've said this a million times
you know fun is subjective but you're
such a lack of for me the person that
enjoys my new show if I'm telling you
there's a lack of fun in this game you
know there's a lot of red flags um this
is this feels like it is totally 100% of
vanity project for him but at the same
time it's like looking at the whole
product I'm saying like
what what are you trying to say with
this if this is a project for you this
game is for you what are you really
trying to say because it's just batshit
it really that's it it doesn't make any
sense the one overarching story thing
that doesn't feel cheesy and doesn't
feel kind of thrown in your face and I
may be he intended this maybe he didn't
is the way that the multiplayer is sort
of incorporated it's not you don't ever
directly interact with anybody else in
the world what happens is that they can
leave things in the world or you can
leave things for other players in the
world to make their traversal easier so
it's like it has this overarching thing
about you know social media and how we
treat each other on social media like a
game like for instance like there's no
there's no trolling here right there's
no there's no crumb side stranding it's
just helping other people out and I
think that message is cool overall but
the rest of it honestly like he could
have told a much cleaner straighter
story and gotten more gravitas from it
we especially with these actors then
this did this weird thing he's trying to
do wow I haven't played not under this
rock will even see a rope with you guys
what is your experience with the dead
stranding I'm gonna call it V that's
right be dextran mine's gonna be a bit
different surprising when you write I
honestly thought like when you asked me
to be on here I was like yeah I'm
probably gonna come on here and talk
about how I don't like this game
but mm-hmm I'm not gonna do that it you
know when I first saw this game you know
the trailer air could try to be
different that's all that time trust me
trust me I really went in with like low
expectations let me let me put that out
there I really thought based on the
trailers I was not gonna like this game
especially when it came to like the
micromanaging the balancing all of that
I just figured that's going to be
cumbersome it's gonna be annoying and
but I always thought well maybe this
story I think the story looks
interesting I'll probably dig it for
that if I do play it so I decided I'm
gonna check it out I'm at a Redbox it
thank you
it's safe just in case I don't like it
and all the things you described the
game really well by the way like as far
as like what you do in the game you you
pretty what you see is what really you
get you're delivering packages you're
walking around a lot the focus is on
balance it's on you know walking
properly not falling not damaging the
package it sounds crazy right we just
just follow me so that's what you do as
far as it's so crazy just might work
maybe and but that's like your mechanics
it's the core mechanics and I agree I
agree that it's like these little things
that were in games before you know all
the stuff I just explained but Kojima he
puts it at the forefront this is like
the main core of the game and so the
story as I expected is interesting it's
easy to understand at least so far like
you said on the surface because I don't
know if later on we're gonna be peeling
later layers and it's gonna get all you
know weird or anything but so far I've
been able to understand it on the
surface but like like I'm saying I have
a different opinion because I don't find
it boring like I thought I was going to
which is really surprising to me I've
been playing it I've been streaming it
and maybe that has to do with it I gotta
throw that in there as a factor you know
chatting with the stream yeah certain
people crack jokes you know the FedEx
jokes the Amazon jokes we're having a
good time right so as I'm playing the
game I'm actually having fun with it all
you got to do is stream the game maybe
that's the trick yeah I do I do already
that's made the stream but let me go
ahead and get these super traps real
quick okay okay so I want you to get
this uh this dizzy warlord king well
that would happen if I'm not wearing
shades and it's not early in the morning
Lord Lords of Sunday
another day to remind you that King Olav
needs another day to remind you that
kijima
is a egotistical maniac hashtag all men
the bushes
thank you dizzy I think you're onto
something with Rome in the bushes in the
teespring stores now anyway yes dizzy I
understand you know what I was just
talking about dizzy yesterday and I said
how he's such an inspiration to me and
he should be an inspiration to a lot of
people and I will always go back to his
picture where he's sitting in his
hospital bed he's sick this is our
editor-in-chief going through it right
now I will love you for you guys to go
to his arm his GoFundMe page and
contribute to him but he has a control
in his hand and me and I'm talk and I
said oh that's what I thought but he
said he wasn't playing destiny he's
playing something else because the UM
the the Wi-Fi was terrible there but I
said man if you look like he was in a
raid or something he was I saw your
passion and it just broke my heart
because this man is 100% gaming and he's
here every Sunday and he's full of
support and all I can do is just be be
in admiration of this man this man is an
incredible dude and I think about him
every day to be honest with you never
met him in person but I think about him
every day
put the GoFundMe contribute anything to
the Lord's are definitely appreciative
so we got another suit a $2 super trap
from brat he says that it's a death
straining coke classic so now we've went
there already all right gotcha Bratton
we got a $5 super trap from the Ashton
Luke always good to hear Erika's voice
what's up Lords hope you're having a
good day now harassing people for
enjoying dead stranding you know what's
sad I listen to too you know lady Lucas
so much I actually read that in her
voice but we're gonna go beyond that
toluca going on yeah where was I so yeah
like I was saying I really thought I was
gonna come on here and and
under this game like say it's boring and
I don't like it but though weird it's
just such a trip this game it's the
weirdest thing is I'm doing these you
know quote-unquote tedious things I'm
walking I'm delivering I'm taking care
of this baby it's crying I'm shaking it
I actually should well this was like the
one major time because I'm like four to
five hours in and this was the main time
where it's like oh you need to calm this
baby down cuz the the the thing that
it's in it was red and I'm looking at it
like oh shoot I gotta do something so I
take it out I have it in his hands and I
had to actually move the controller to
comment down so I was like well I'm
really doing this I'm really playing
this game I'm doing exactly what I knew
was gonna happen in this game and I
thought I was gonna hate it but because
I'm streaming like I said I'm laughing
about it I'm joking around I was kind of
enjoying it it's the weirdest thing and
and I can't really articulate or express
why it's enjoyable but there's something
about it there's something about it that
just like keeps me going and the story
like it is good so that you know plays a
part plays a huge part actually because
it gives motivation to the character I
feel like he has a reason for what he's
doing and that I think gives it more
purpose and it gives me more reason to
keep playing
so I'm tripping out on myself trust me
this is this is something I did not
expect to be saying I really did not
think I was going to feel this way but I
actually do and I'm pleasantly surprised
I'm pleasantly surprised and I gotta say
we just hit no I read I read boxed it
and that thing had to go back at nine
o'clock last night I'm looking at my
husband I'm like what am I gonna do
should I should I take it back he takes
it back from me right he comes back with
a purchased death stranding and hands it
to me he's like here I have now own
death stranding everybody didn't want to
give it back and he knew it and he sort
of
you know that's tragedy you know from
what I see on it it doesn't it looks
interesting what I see but you know as
of right now you know I'll eventually
get to it the biggest thing I'm really
looking forward to on the PlayStation
brand is Final Fantasy 7 remake
obviously so I probably get so I don't
know probably it'll be on PC by then too
but we got a $10 super chat from wrap
again the game is actually more than a
walking simulator it has present
pleasantly surprised me I'm hooked it
bucked the usual troops and nice changes
of pace from what I played this
generation I will say and that's I
expected nothing less from Kojima like I
know full well that at some point in the
middle of that game or even before then
you're gonna hit something it's like wow
I didn't expect this to be here I know
this game if you play any games you
gonna know sooner or later you're gonna
have that wow factor it could be a good
Wow or a bad Wow but you have that wow
factor but you're gonna get a change of
pace there that you're not gonna see in
a lot of other games like he's he's
super courageous in that regard like he
doesn't care like he will do that um but
yeah I mean back I mean to the point
that some people are saying like you
know I guess I guess people are getting
sort of shamed for playing the game
I'm not saying anybody who playing a
game day you got they got my $60
straight off
Kojima has my money um but I just think
what bothers me about this is that it
just he really does make games for
himself and when we talk about the fact
that he's you know he's obviously gonna
get into movies and whatnot I really do
feel like that is a medium where that is
suited to him and in that I would love
to see a DES training movie right
without take away all of these all of
these mechanics and stuff like that
just tell this story right and then have
to condense it in into a two and a half
hour thing I think it would be good for
him right I don't know that it
necessarily be successful but I think
that's something I think if he practiced
at Kojima movies would be fantastic
because he comes up with these
off-the-wall ideas that it just nuts and
don't make any sense and it just stupid
sometimes but you in a game you have you
know 6070 whatever hundred hours of
exposition you have to fill right right
in a movie if he's forced to have to
condense that I think we can get some of
some really really special stuff and I
the man is a legend I think his
production I do think you can tell a
story better than he can make a game I
don't think he can tell a story well at
all I believe like BG says he's
intentionally that are more accepting to
that and then the game jump I don't I
don't think so I don't think the
audience would like to sit there through
his egotistical rants and his maniacal
misleading he goes out of his way to
explain things that should just you
should should be open to interpretation
right you explain it in a way that it
doesn't respect his audience sometimes
like it makes it look dumb and that's
the thing that I think if he's makes
movies he has to he's forced to have to
cut out that fat right yes come with a
story tell it as directly and straight
as you can and the funny thing is when
you do that everything else around it
sort of picks up the movie right like
the character interactions and stuff
like that see he makes interesting
characters I don't know that the
interactions with those characters are
very interesting they're very sort of
stilted and cardboard like but the
characters themselves are interesting
like he he doesn't have any sort of
interactions that feel like a naughty
dog game interaction between like Nathan
trinket and Elena or something like that
not even close and if he had that I
think you would have truly special
products all the way around you guys who
played it what's up with everybody
crying I mean he did he get down the
crying animation now to a point that
he's trying to make everybody cry
there is a story to it right there is a
story thing to it has to do with the
time fall I believe
beyond that there is a story thing to it
but yeah at the same time he is showing
off I mean it's really real quick before
we continue we got a $2.00 super jet
from brat this is to you address to you
Erica it says Erica do the BTS freaked
you out
I hate thing uh they do they freak me
out
I don't know about freaking out but it
does kind of get the tension up because
you gotta like hold your breath you got
to move slowly you got a crouch you got
a manager because your stamina goes down
someone killed and uh and until dawn
because I couldn't hold my breath
correctly because it's now the Cutie
right that was I kept that chick alive
the whole game it was it was the keep
distill I used to put the controller
down if I knew that was gonna car I
cheated I don't care but that one time I
remember I would never forget I was I
try to keep that it was um it was Sam I
tried to keep her alive the whole game
got to the very end and they the
animation program it I never tried to
sit so still in my whole life all I
thought was the red show up and that she
got clap I'm like no yeah I I sucked at
the game I think I had like two people
survive or something wonderful but uh no
back to death drowning uh I yeah it's
more like a tense situation but you
don't really die or there's not really a
huge I mean I think your your packages
might get damaged I think if you do get
caught you do you can like shake them
off as it tries to grab you and stuff
it's really hard to get a bad grade
I'm not grant granted I'm playing on
normal so I don't know if you plan hard
it makes it like you have to have a less
percentage of damage because it gives
you a percentage but I think again the
cheat that we're utilizing yeah right
right so um yeah but as far as the BTS
that's probably been some of the best
moments though because I mean some
people might look at it differently
right you might think of it like it's
exciting but then others might think
well duh you've been
bored for the past hour so of course
when something happens it's gonna be
exciting so who knows what it really is
and what's really going on but it is a
moment where you kind of like you get a
little nervous and you don't want them
to see you and so you slow things down
even more and it gets you know the
tension goes up so yeah it does and
they're always more than you expect like
you see if you if you throw out your
scanner your scanner should kind of show
you an outline of the ones that are like
sort of immediately in front of you when
you traverse right through them I
thought I was in the clear and then all
of a sudden you have like 10 more that
appeared I guess that you know it's just
it's an area that you have to get
through with them and then the thing is
at the same time you also like BB is is
agitated so BB kind of fidget and cry so
you have to make sure that he stays
quiet I was gonna be mad if there was no
BB and nobody's throat but I said you
see that in the it's actually the same
cutscene that they show from before so
yeah they throw baby is a thing you know
what's you know oh yeah yeah hold on
pause that's right Bo you're right thank
you sir appreciate it well let me let me
say I don't play a lot of Kojima games I
played Metal Gear Solid 5 but based on
like the audience and the fanboys and
the hype because people just praise
Kojima up and down like he's he's the
god today the god right
good lady Erica salut what's going on
sir chillin chillin fresh off that
Dallas flight with the great wedding
[Laughter]
look down just everybody's consensus was
you know as far as the people who play
just like they like it is it like solve
and Erica I believe you two played so
what's the consensus for me pleasantly
surprised I really thought I was not
gonna like the you know the mechanics of
the game just the constant you know
balancing of my packages walking around
and climbing and and all of that and
it's surprisingly not boring to me and
it's interesting the story is
interesting and I've talked about that a
little bit we both we both talked about
it but it's it's easy to understand and
so far and it's just one of those things
where it's like I feel like I shouldn't
like it but I do and I can't really
figure out why it's just sort of like
this thing it's like I want to keep at
it I want to see what's gonna happen
kind of thing I wanted to also say that
because we're talking about movies and
how Kojima should get into movies I I
really do think this would make a great
Netflix
and I kind of feel like that's what I'm
doing like I'm playing a Netflix series
I I'm interested in that kind of way so
that's I wanted to mention that too so
actually the story which took the thing
I was would get to solve I just was
curious because basically the thing I
had the most worried about was the story
being convoluted you know he'd be on his
Lane Lee Lallu stuff and yes Erica's
saying she's actually good with that
that the story seems good now what's
also just curious real quick no I I
definitely agree with that like the
story it's it's it's weird and you know
there's weird characters and weirdly
named characters for no reason
but yeah but it is does seem fairly
straightforward which is weird to say
but it's juicy it's so far at least it's
fairly straightforward attention to all
the cutscenes it's up like that you
should not be lost
but uh yeah I'm not as high on it as
everything that I played so far and like
I said for me the king of my new show
for me not to like it it kind of
surprised me actually I said I'm gonna
like this game I know and these guys
gonna kill me for it and they um at this
point
it hasn't opened up enough that I am
that I'm enjoying what I'm playing but I
may just be stupid enough is it hmm
barrel through and keep for me I mean
and for me like I don't begrudge anybody
liking it for whatever reason because it
does have it does have some some some
qualities that are pretty great but the
moment-to-moment stuff for me is not do
was not there so so basically this stuff
people was saying with the core gameplay
loop was a low that's what you're
harping on you're not there with it it's
on point that that definitely is on
point and there that's objectively what
it is and it's a matter whether you
you're down with that are you not down
with that it wasn't anybody embellishing
what the gameplay loop is yoga it is
that and it's just a matter if it if
it's for you or not like I said but I I
did say like the story the acting itself
is I found to be very good and like all
the actors kind of really being all in
on their parts like
it seems very it doesn't seem
disingenuous in any way shape or form
like poker Norman Reedus sounds like
Norman Reedus so he may sound yeah he
gave his Darrell long so exactly so he
means not like phoning it in a little
bit but that was him but everything else
honestly it has great parts to it this
the things about it they're fantastic
that code you know when it comes to like
when it comes to tech and stuff like
that like it really shows off that
engine there's other things that are for
me our disappointment now last cause I
know I know I'm annoying adequate this
is like I got asked
I heard the decima is fired okay that
gave me like oh damn halo is gonna look
fantastic in horizon 2 I thought the
same thing like that that games gonna
look gorgeous Wow I think I'm done
boring you know I've had to ask those
questions you know it's been a mystery
so we've definitely talked about this
story not even just today I'm looking
forward to never talking about this game
that same way at it cuz you know all
these podcasts like everybody talking
about this guy was like man you know I
can't wait till it this game comes and
goes playing the damn thing it's like
you never know with videogames you just
never know this ain't being
disrespectful on the screen so how great
is that is true there's often times it's
a barren way so I think somebody to say
called it the well what do they call it
the newsela the new zealand walking
simulator because like this game comes
off a pc we're gonna be talking about it
again when the game comes out for game
pass we're gonna be talking about it
again so um the team was gonna be just
like throw baby I'll shout the video
stay tuned our super check Kevin Costner
DLC incoming
Datak a desk it's okey you know till
Kings right we're gonna talk about this
for the DC version comes out I'm
confident we will or when it emanated
for game of the year because you know
I'm gonna tell you this though if this
wins game with you keel is it media bias
he's gonna have to shove his head in a
hole somewhere for like the next two
years
it'll get nominated
I got a static I apologize or you're
tougher to good but I gotta ask this is
a very polarizing big man like SH I got
the braaap of the chat I saw boom going
at it like if this wings gave it a year
is it a problem it is it is it the the
Keighley influence he's in the game I
got I got asked to show it a couple of
times I think he can influence it to get
put in the nominations but I don't think
he has any control if he gets nominated
it's not gonna matter he doesn't have
even though III did you know I think I
think if this game wins game of the year
you will hear an audible groan from the
crowd go back a couple years when
overwatch will gave you because that's
gonna be delivered and everybody wants
their packages to come and say he's
dropped this game at package time of the
year everybody want a little Christmas
presents and all this stuff so these
guys out here being amateur delivery
people and listen I'm telling you all
these little amateur delivery people is
gonna go
gonna vote for this game and it's going
windy you know what I'm on or something
I'm gonna vote for forget about this we
didn't talk about the Mules Erica the
the mules are essentially former
Porter's package delivers their delivery
crackheads so to speak saying that I was
just saying that on my stream like this
is really low-key adrylek exchange right
now Wow always delivery drugs all the
time so I'm like whoa did I just crack
the code here am i in my they say you
need these drugs at the outpost because
the post solitaire that they need things
to keep them even cute because then
they'll go crazy so they need the drugs
you know the middle guy who people that
was distributed Heisenberg they call
them mule
people move their weight and
post-apocalyptic world was very vocal
about speaking about this
she actually changed his topic because
this came up you know we want to talk
about game paths and obviously Lord King
is very very pro game path so I'm gonna
hand it off there oh not the neogaf or
coming up with that somebody has
deciphered this is the subscription
numbers on game packs looking at 9.5
million now I know a lot of you guys
gonna be like the king is has not been
confirmed it's confirmed in the realm so
listen if this is the adoption rate on
getting passed don't hit me with sales
numbers you amateurs stockholders wrong
pocket watch the situation I'm just
talking about from the aspect of gaming
right if this the trend is just the turn
is this the ignition point where people
and and and everybody is voting with the
fact that the real pocket watches real
budgeters are actually budgeting and
figuring out game pastors that such a
value any services is that such a value
that this is giving back to their family
they actually have more money to go on
vacations and stop you know get diapers
for babies and stuff their children's I
walk around with no diapers that they
wanted to get def stranded shout out
that I do that don't have racer but you
know I'm seeing adoption rate and if
this is is this is correct at 9.5
million and you say everybody's been
talking about everybody Xbox have stayed
at all 50 million since last year right
like the episode in the Xbox's this last
year but let's keep that same energy
right and let's say it's 50 million and
you got close to 10 million game pass on
subscribers that's a large core that you
have linked into and is this the new
trend going forward if this if these
numbers is to believe is Microsoft right
I did and I bring this to the roundtable
and I took my other topic off because I
think this is a more polarizing and more
interesting topic if game passes really
at 9 plus million do you think that you
know if they came out and they formally
announced that these are their numbers
do you think that would shut some of
these people up that's on Twitter as far
as like what the haters the pocket watch
this subscription service is something
that could be done long term that games
are going to be devalued in quality but
9 million you know regardless what
people want to have this narrative
everyone's not paying a dollar right no
yeah I fully agree with that I know
that's for sure because that's just how
you start off and then once you get kind
of you know into the plan then it goes
up to what 15 or something like that
yeah I did just come off my ultimate
subscription for gears you know I let it
expire but you know I got on there and
so anybody who really you know gets on
there they're not gonna be like me to
remember to end it some stay on it and
then they end up really liking it too so
these don't stay on it for that so but
for the haters and all of that I don't
know I mean I go back and forth with
with being a hater sometimes because
sometimes I think well maybe it is
messing up these games like gears for
example who they are on you know this
terrible plan as far as content and how
its rolling out and you know yeah
they're trying to do micro transactions
and things like that so I worry about
that part
like my games that I love like gears of
war if it's gonna ruin my you know games
that I like so I do I do kind of dabble
in that that that mindset like maybe
maybe it could hurt these games I do I
do think about that sometimes but then
at the same time I know I'm not a
businesswoman I did not go to school for
business so they're obviously doing they
know like a Bachelor in marketing or
something related like most of these
people couldn't sell strawberries at the
grocery store and they say try to act
like they know how a subscription
service works and then they're
constantly comparing it to Netflix which
it's not even a fair comparison because
Netflix doesn't sell anything
Xbox does Netflix doesn't have a
subscription service card got live which
regardless I don't believe they should
have that but Xbox does you know they
have multiple places of Avenue that they
can make money off that brings into game
paths being the entry so we got a $5 to
$4.99 super chat from being her it says
games in Disney World you pay to get in
and then spend more on toys DLC game
pass essentially Disney setting and
stories and that don't enter just
selling in stores in a free dinner it's
cool now let Erica finish you had a good
point on the other side she was saying
to be Lively right now but no I mean
like I said oh yeah saying I'm not a
businesswoman Microsoft they have a ton
of money so they're they know what their
dime assuming they know what they're
doing and long term I think they'll be
fine I just kind of worry about certain
franchises because I'm seeing it before
my eyes Gears of War it's changing
before my eyes it might be too late at
this point and I know you feeling I
gotta ask you this Erica do you feel
like it the the microtransaction aspect
you feel like the game past day had a
negative effect on just a rollout of the
content after launch I'm saying it's
it's possible I think that's a factor it
could be a factor yeah
yeah for sure enough Wells jumping in
what are you for solve how do you feel
about this game pass I mean I think I
think the thing with Microsoft and why
this works is just because they do have
that cushion where if it's slow to
startup if and it's the adoption rate is
slow they can eat that so that's that's
what that's what they have over say a
Sony that maybe can't necessarily or
wouldn't want to eat that in the
beginning to have that slow build up
Microsoft me had to do this and and they
can do it right and think about it is
there is just a they pay every single
one of these developers upfront right
some some lump sum of money that the
developer is nobody's put holding a gun
to their head right there paint them
with this lump sum the days they're
saying okay - in addition to continuing
to get exposure on this platform right
and it's just I think the exposure is
what matters the most because sitting in
the public conversation long after in
that that initial two-week period when
when a game usually makes the most of
his money is no you constantly keep it
in in that in that conversation it may
not matter in that conversation to the
heart go home already played it in that
initial period right but I'll tell you
right now the batsman is looking at is
how do we get the person who only buys
two or three games a year maybe in two
game past because at that point then you
have somebody there who only purchases
specific games was gonna look at this at
this platform and say why not right I
have a perfect example of a co-worker of
mine the other day he was looking up
dying like the enhanced edition for a
son who's gonna buy a physical copy
right mm-hmm and it's not in gamepad I
thought it was but I mentioned game
pants that's like if you heard a game
pass and she's like no what was that I'm
like whoa it's it's a service that you
can pay either $10 or $15 a month and it
folds everything and when I mentioned
ultimate because he's not a PC gamer but
ultimate because of the fact that it
includes
um live she was super interested
immediately when I bought a year's worth
the game past in addition to buying him
a copy of Dynalite the enhanced edition
this is somebody who under no
circumstances would have found this
known about it any way shape or form now
it's probably in for the duration
because she says like you know here's
his regular xbox live just gets taken
out of my account every month I don't
even pay attention to it right it's
something that they're banking on right
nine million nine and a half million as
we go into next gen look look for that
to double mmm because again they're only
gonna sweeten the pot my hope is that X
cloud gets rolled into the world without
an extra without and because somebody
got an email that they were in and I'm
I'm really upset you got to go you gotta
make some calls I'm refraining from
doing that you can play your switch sir
let them hit you why captain I see the
perspective but it's hard to blame
subscription services on changes in
gears etc until or unless something like
that happens regularly if it doesn't
it's unrelated if it does then I agree
so it could be isolated it could be what
is the issue with geared specifically
well it's more about the
microtransactions he has huge issues
when the game launched what you know
heard it now I don't think the quality
of the actual games the issue
now there was bugs when the game came
out but a lot of those in there fixed I
know people I have issues with the the
stats tracking because I know they were
still having issues with that obviously
they had the whole thing happened where
they were banning people for two up to
two years so you know that heard them
and then it's gotten to the point with
the cosmetics how you unlock stuff in
the multiplayer people want the loot box
stuff back from Gears for that's how bad
that should tell you everything that
people actually prefer the lunchboxes
and we complain about those old wine
before but to say I'd rather have those
that's that's bad I just tells you
extremely fixable like you know go
towards a little bit more the destiny
route where you know as much as I hate
to say this you know III complained
about ever us a lot one we could have
the gears wayward you literally have to
pay for you have a season you could get
stuff it from the previous season for
the silver but for a lot of stuff that
season you got the Bob okay I was gonna
say as a Gears fan I'm gonna throw this
in there and this is just kind of just
how I feel about the franchise they they
casualized it a lot and I remember I
remember hearing from I think it was Rod
Fergusson or some one of the developers
saying we want people to log into game
pass see our game and check it out and
they really wanted to make this game for
everyone which I understand I mean it
makes sense it's like this feeling of
like participation trophies you get you
get eliminations four assists now you
don't really get to know yeah yeah that
that's true I don't like I like in
battlefield how if you get like I think
it's 80% of the kill
you get kids to kill too because I
nothing irritates me more then literally
laid someone down in destiny and then
sinister pops up in shotguns you know
but in in in the world everything is we
we like to look at ourselves as the
end-all be-all we are to 10% yeah we're
trying to get that other 90% and just
like we saw the fight with Keira SIA and
Logan Paul you know they packed out an
arena and these guys are not the 10%
represented the 90% the 90% was those
people that were there so for him to say
that he wants people to look at his game
yeah he wants more than that 10% piece
of the pie he was 90% he was a hundred
percent around the board yeah 10 percent
for you guys they want to hide behind
cover and pop people in the neck yeah
but what about that guy that don't get
that kill but he got that assist doesn't
that guy engaged changing that's going
forward yeah the only people I had
crying about all gears has changed in
any form of fashion as these hardcore
sweaty that's what I can be I definitely
can be yeah you're right you're right I
probably am in the minority
you know the participation trophies just
it's it's hard to really put my finger
on sometimes but there have been videos
and stuff going around about the
aim-assist
that they kind of put in there not to my
knowledge I don't think they've actually
really addressed it they've mostly been
addressing other things and fixing the
bugs and things like that but superbrat
did you guys hear my participa I
definitely butchered his name we're
starting the challenges of subscription
services regarding devaluing the growth
and mature gaming markets no I didn't I
did I did yeah it's um it's interesting
you know I'm saying is you gotta
understand like game pass they're still
in the infancy stages and there's a lot
of things
we have to see how this thing matures
how it goes and you know in comparison
to other subscription services out there
we've never seen this it will gave me we
have to see so I think it's a risk that
might like Erica say like it's a risk
Microsoft is willing to check based on
their pocket watching of their own
finances you know they will how much
millions we got to see I mean they
clearly have this strategy for a reason
as far as the whole let me jump in real
quick as far as the whole was at nine
point five million thing or whatever
yeah I don't know man you know the the
whole thing way was a gaffe I believe if
you remember correctly at Gamescom or
was it last year's XO he said they had a
couple million already like to defray
they probably do I mean that the problem
is Microsoft is not divulging the
numbers right so we still can't
officially know now again I don't think
so right
I don't think Phil's keep that same
energy because you know what you know
you lend yourself to more criticism when
you start talking about your
accomplishments you don't talk about
your defeats that's energy right no
matter what you must hold that line and
let your actions speak for itself
if you adopt that philosophy and he's
adopted that philosophy so Dom you know
we we shall not be speaking on any
numbers in that same mantra because if
at any point you change you're going to
be vilified in ways that you have no
idea let's see is the only thing I
disagree with is that I hear what you're
saying with that and I was fine with
that when they of tip that approach with
the MPD stuff they like we ain't doing
this council style stale so stuff no
more we're gonna do engage in it right
game pass is their number one thing for
engagement and it is like so it's like
yo now we that do it again so why guess
my thing is again I'm cynical I'm
skeptical of always I'm not saying I do
well it could be good say but Kirk I
would just like to have that transparent
no it okay subscription number
as numbers is not engagement now you can
say engagement right you can try to
extrapolate the number out of that what
equates to each person so if you say we
have engagement numbers that rival 300
million hours Glade in a week and then
to try to extrapolate that into what
each hour works out for each person
somebody gives you that that's their
business I don't think they take away
from that I think that will be announced
as far as the engagement level and if
your percentage on the uptake in what
people are actually doing inside a game
past to show you the positive results at
no point in time do I think they devote
the exact number of how many people are
actively subscribed to Dave supergiant's
tax bought my pops a year worth the game
pass ultimate for his birthday and
having gotten a call from him since he's
been locked guess who earned his big
piece of deep-fried I hope you enjoy
your fried turkey man got to see my og
motivate like that name just gonna get
I've always on the side of transparency
so again when the opposition is doing it
I just would like Microsoft to do it you
know I'm saying now it's up to them of
course you know I'm saying but it again
do we really know the hard and fast
numbers I don't think so you know I'm
saying so to me this is still all
speculation I think it's a great service
value for the game like I told y'all
before I don't care I ain't pocket
watching it's better for me it's better
for gamers so let it continue you know
saying that's ultimately where I'm at
with it yeah I'm with that too
it's good for us so I mean what are we
worried about you know but yeah you
definitely have people out here like why
are you so cheap I've had people tell me
it on Twitter like why don't you just
support the game go buy the game you're
cheap like a dollar on my PC you're
telling me to go out she said you have
one spectrum of people calling me cheap
because I have game pass and then you
have one spectrum of people the same
people saying that I'm go chain game
because I'm buying the elite controller
- you can't win you know what I'm going
to be cheap and and if that calls is
that way I listen I'm fine with it um I
think I don't think there's anybody on
this planet they can call me cheat me
gee but if I see value in something I
don't care what you think you keep up
with me in games this is what I'm gonna
tell you I'm gonna go get those 200 200
games from a little 14 dollars a month
right I'm gonna do this and I want you
to buy all 200 games to keep up with me
is like again you're always we always
argue a point that we come from right
and we you don't step away from it and
say all right what is the the person
that isn't the hardcore gamer how do
they see this right right and I think
that is that is what they're looking at
they know they have us in pocket they
were worried about how to get everybody
else in pocket and again how many people
purchase a console one cos a one console
for their home right and per and
purchase one two three games here they
play Madden they'll play fee for
whatever they'll play Call of Duty and
maybe that's it I'll earn it because
then that just buys Madden every year
that's really all mm-hmm
but if de you were able to convince him
like look man for 10 bucks a month do
you have access to all these games maybe
you like one or two of them like
whatever but it's just 10 bucks a month
you're not gonna feel it that's what
they want that's what they want and
that's what I'm gonna get like you know
me like more and more that's what
they're gonna get so it's just you know
sometimes you've got to step away from
your perspective on the argument and and
see it from someone
I gotta address chief Tommy straight-up
fraud my dues a king you're not even
playing half those games in-game past
let me tell you something sir I'm not
playing half the games that I got I have
over 500 360 games all right more than
500 360 games I sold all my PlayStation
3 games to get a PlayStation 4 well
because I didn't think they were gonna
need that fraud alert right you know I
have 200 games in there that I'm not
playing but on average I check out one
game per week that I would never buy and
would never sit there and put a quarter
a nickel dime or penny into this game I
was never buying ukelele sir and I mean
it right so who did that for me Phil
dominus Maximus 600 $700 statue that's
behind me it's not finances with me
brother this is gonna be a issue with me
but the thing is is absolute value
because I would never in this a lifetime
run down to the store and say oh let me
buy this ukulele for free - super - at
last - super - okay shout out to one bad
mother with the 499 super test game fly
use games and free-to-play devalued
games - let's worry about whether it's
working for us
playing the long game yes they are yes
t-tube rap with the $2 superjet somebody
gave us first party day and date not
some things to say about that look Brad
that was very timely because we'll be
talking about that in a moment
the Ryan is trying to put himself atop
the mountain cuz you gonna crack your
lips on alright so we've had some other
leadership changes that's happened
Yoshida has stepped down he is now in
charge of the Indies you know I don't
know this is he in charge of the
department that that goes out and seeks
Indies he will be leading a new company
initiative to support independent
developers that's gonna be his new role
oh yes
co course II do see left right and uh
you know I would not see G of course his
position was not at the level that you
see this position with that right so
what I wanna ask people is do you think
that all of this changing of leadership
is going to affect the PS 5 and if you
do think it's going to affect it anyway
how would you feel like it would affect
her or maybe you just don't feel like
it's going affect at all maybe you feel
that they had all their ducks in a row
before they started doing these because
I feel like when you have a change of
leadership this dress because this is
just one person right he's still in the
company but he's not in that position
anymore and you know you got a lot of
the people that really were responsible
for the ps4 era they're not there
anymore they're not even in the same
position
hashtag not my tummy no cuz I will never
be able to pass the torch name and I'm
gonna do that right now before I got to
the bushes shoot the shot anyway alright
so we got was at hosts he was the
co-founder for guerilla and now you know
he's gonna be running things man he's
best known for Killzone horizon zero
dawn all that good stuff and then you
she did now going to the independent
support independent developers so that's
what pretty much a new role for him I
was to take a look at like Twitter and
some of the Sony base to see where they
were coming at and a lot of them are
very positive about the move they're
saying that you know for the most part
they saying like how Sony kind of
dropped the ball with indie since the
start of the PlayStation 4 generation
when he came out out the gate like
superhot you know it was all about the
you know wrestle guns and all that other
stuff and then it kind of went away from
meetings and if you look at it at the
beginning Xbox really wasn't about the
Indies and then now they're kind of in
that spot with Sharla and IO and Xbox
and all that stuff so that's the first
thing and then um yeah humming host you
know people feel that's a good fit to
they said he was on with Sony for a long
time they fed or most importantly also I
don't know if responsible for decima but
you know he's one of the people that
helped Shepherd it and that's something
looks like they're gonna really be
relying on an engine for ps5 you know
for me personally the vibe I get if you
listen to Jim Ryan he had a great
interview at games industry tapas and
the vibe he's talking about was that
there's three Playstations that there's
the it was always the us to European and
Japan and they all stopped operated as
separate
entities and now they're trying to do
this globalization centric stuff and you
know now like a lot of people say hey if
it wasn't broke why fix it I know what
you're going at it cuz a lot of people
feel the same same way you know it's
gonna be it's gonna remain to be seen I
mean I I do agree with him that they
needed to be centralized I do agree them
that you know what Xbox is doing is
really competitive coming in to next gen
and I think they're positioning
themselves and putting their feet on the
pedal the only thing I can concern about
where I probably would add a concave Ike
I think I'm gonna agree with them is
that I always get nervous when it's this
amount of shake up like you have it's
one thing okay one person I got it it
just feels like the last 3i LPS we've
talked about someone leaving moving
shifting changing right so all you have
all I can say is I hope all this
infrastructure stuff pans out for them
because this is a lot of turnover we'll
see I mean on paper it sounds like the
right move but again I have to see what
is this much turnover at the top one
leaves me a little concerned they have
everything on debt for PlayStation
because let me let me put this I'm not
gonna read them live on cog we do
because yes Jonathan B has been with us
and is reaching and our chat forever and
let me tell you something Jonathan B has
never dropped a nickel in this chat and
it takes something to move this man put
a nickel in this chat and let me tell
you I truly appreciate you being here
sir I'm a pocketwatch and I'm not
shaming you I'm gonna telling you I know
something had to move you today
just focusing on when is my turn let's
get let's get lady Erica so he still is
that Sony he's doing honestly I mean I
think it's a good thing I don't think
it's necessarily a bad thing I don't
think the how many has there been cuz
I've been sort of out of the loop you
know hasn't been that many late in Ryan
then we got what was that dev Saab that
we talked about that he just went away
from controller to guy the Ayatollah
[Music]
there was the the Japanese car
part also with a lady in that thing that
also left at the same time know the full
turnaround let's just not forget this
handful of people I mean they're
important people there's those names
right I know who they are so yeah I mean
it's interesting I mean maybe I mean I
don't want to speak too soon before ps5
comes out maybe the the direction
they're going with it maybe there's
something they're trying to focus on I'm
kind of worried about but I mean as far
as the console itself and what how it's
gonna perform and all that they they got
those ducks in the line like you said
that's ready to go I mean they just got
to make it and ship it and get it ready
for next year I think five is what it is
net what what they contributed to it if
they did that's what it's gonna be and
they left their mark already I think
that's I think she was involved at all
yeah it's it's done that's how I feel
like that's why I was fine so you feel
that he already put his part in so they
got rid of my part I'm gonna go focus on
this now and his idea okay did this guys
I'm just gonna Stephanie young let me
flex real quick I actually met you hey
[Music]
[Applause]
never said no to a picture I have a
picture this guy he's cool and and so I
don't know man I I just feel like Sony
they're fine it's probably gonna take a
lot for me to think like oh man they're
really messing up now like that piece
fives gotta make do some damage
something's gotta happen for me to see
some effects like okay this mattered
them down or whatever like I don't want
to speak too soon and think it's the
world or anything because people do that
with it with Xbox yeah oh left and it's
doom and gloom but then
they're quiet it's like what's up what's
really I don't want to do one of those
where I dated cuz for one I don't really
know everything that's going on Yin yeah
[ __ ] is not doing big things no place
Chris I'm gonna tell you now man I like
you but stop fraud yourself if if we CEO
she to leave within the next couple of
months
cubicle and this is gonna come out the
fact that they put him in charge of
Indies is interesting for a couple of
reasons one you know that at the start
of this this path this generation they
was wrong with Indies and that's that
kind of put them over the top a little
bit where they had these games if
Microsoft just wasn't even addressing to
forget it it had nothing in the works
they had they had a lock on it right now
I'll tell you this when it comes to
PlayStation now if they're gonna push
PlayStation now bigger obviously they've
made that they've already said we're not
putting our first party big games day
and date day one right how do you
mitigate that you get somebody like
Shuhei in charge of getting Indies day
and date day one to look more similar to
game past not exactly game fast but I
think if you put somebody like show
Seeta Yoshida at the helm of something
like that that makes sense because
that's a game path light it game past
light okay like they're not doing not
doing that big time first party thing
now if if ever right I don't think
that's that's but to me they're looking
at game past and they're seeing indie
games day and a day one launching on
their they've seen out of wars launching
in game character in addition to
launching everywhere else
day in day I think if I think this could
be what that is that you should they're
putting your shoot in position where he
has to make PlayStation now into
something more akin to game pass right
that is an important job Rohit don't go
oh we got Brandon Brett what's up
I want to thank I want to thank Lord
addict for the invite and let me tell
you something guys I put down death's
training to be here because my Lords
podcast more importantly I wanted to
introduce myself
your guest Erica her YouTube is in the
chat right now we have a $5 tip from
dizzy Sony has one meeting with overseer
Sith Lord I'm definitely not trying to
butcher that when starts firing and
rearranging everyone everything is going
according to plan
let's get respective man I mean
obviously we seen a lot of shake up
going on
you know people changing roll your sheet
has got to do a roll you know Brava well
yeah weather everything that's happening
on Sony any concern not so you know it's
a good thing well yeah with this I'm not
I'm not really concerned I you know I
think one of the big things that Jim
Ryan said is like you know like
complacent sees a killer like he said
that you know historically speaking the
no there's never been a back-to-back
winner if you will for four console
generations and the fact that they
recognize that and he talked about day
we weren't week we can't be complacent I
think that speaks to a lot of the the
moves that you're seeing them do right
now like you know I think it is I mean I
mean look I think what Erica said I mean
berrak Sony coming out III telling us to
get a second job again I think they're
okay
I don't but I'm not shocked by any of
these moves I think it's they're trying
to centralize things to kind of
streamline the process and how quickly
they put out marketing in games and seem
like there was a lot of redundancies
that were going on having three separate
divisions and let's face it like Sony is
a global brand I mean they'll have those
regional you know figureheads like in
Eastern Europe and
u.s. but this is a global brand and I
think it could sort of make sense for
them to streamline this as much as
possible so then they can pivot if they
need to I mean I think I know we joke
around and I said it earlier the super
chair like Sony needs to put their games
day and date as much as I would love
that I don't think it's gonna happen
anytime soon but I do get the sense that
Jim Ryan even though he said hey you
know we value our games then they're put
they're putting them the reason why I
think they're streamlining things
because if they need to pivot on a dime
they can now do it yes going through red
teaming does in a business but I'm gonna
break that down to you because I've
waited too long
hey let me tell you why you streamline
in business to more palatable for sale
all right so when you have too many
extremities what you're trying to do
you're trying to make a fist in business
and this fist can be sold but you can't
sell a hand that's open because you have
too many extremities out there so every
region was an extremity right so what
they had to do was they had to trim the
fat right and they trim the fat they got
that stuff around they brought the
numbers down to a more palatable number
so when somebody purchases the company
they purchase it as a whole they don't
want all these other stuff and they
don't want to come in as new management
and start cutting off things they want
to purchase it as a whole and they want
to move forward so that's why you got
the view going that's why you have all
these turnarounds with people that are
unstable in their position and they see
we're not privy to all the background
paperwork and stuff that's being talked
about this is why the company's mantra
has flipped
their country the company mantra has
turned from okay we are so Indy
it's fantastic and then when you start
having success with your arm third power
your first party Triple A titles then
you drop your Indies all right
so that allows somebody else like
Microsoft to come up and say hey we have
a program that you guys can get in we
weren't on board this way we didn't have
the infrastructure don't change the
rhetoric they didn't have any games in
the beginning that's what he was doing
indie stuff then when he got the game
they dropped it was like a hot potato
they actually I think was Jim Ryan who
said it like it was like yeah we focus a
lot on Indies in the beginning because
we needed time to get our first part
cool like would you rather not have
content at all and weightless first
party like you know what Microsoft came
to the table with a whole bunch of games
this is not about what what Microsoft is
doing let's not lie here all right they
didn't have any first party games to
push that system with the heaven let's
just be clear really we talked about the
start of the generation right okay
you're talking about it at the beginning
when these guys are 13 your eyes a dead
rising 3 you're gonna have knack 3 um
but this is it right here guys I am
concerned when I think this much level
of turnover in any business business
this level of turnover from the top down
it's not it's not just ok they changed
out this guy or that guy in a
rearranging they changed from the top
down to the bottom if we structure in a
manner the philosophy changed and and
they drop prices on PlayStation now and
he did this listen if they don't put
games date and date it's ok I don't care
they still have the sheeple that's going
to purchase I'm one of the cheapo right
so I will purchase a God of War whenever
it does come out I will purchase a Last
of Us whenever it does come out
about buying anything else so I'm not
really engaging in that company how they
want me to engage with them so they will
have to get a service like PlayStation
now up and running properly for me to
engage in that manner they want me to
engage with them right because on C I'm
not super hardcore with them that much
that I'm buying everything to come out
like concrete Genie and crap like that
I'm not doing any Genie dudes crazy for
concrete genie or MIDI anybody where's
the energy but listen the level of
turnaround should be concerned and
nobody is addressing this stuff that's
going on who you know and when people
when I've seen people leave I think I
see I see I see yeah so so you know I
mean it's not like the thing was Sony
like it's not look they they are
restructuring but they're also bringing
people in who have been with the company
for a long time a guy from guerrilla
games yeah it's been there for a long
time
Jim Ryan's been there for a long time
there's still key people that are in the
organization that they're just moving up
to the ranks now no I don't you said
Brad okay I just want to jump in real
quick cuz I'm in the same situation the
same situation where my company as an IT
company and then you know we kind of
went to a huge restructuring there was a
buyout I will say this you're right it
does happen a lot more times than you
think
no oh we gotta drop
okay it's cause I'm rose on my screen
yeah crashed again in the chat I don't
know
YouTube that yeah see you do it just
it's just spinning yeah yeah good we're
lying just as we good now all the sails
dislike you know I've been on both sides
of it I've seen the restructuring aspect
and I've seen two things one it does
Tremont parlor people's redundant
positions are gonna get cut right so
people who were doing one thing in
Europe or whatever people are gonna lose
jobs that that's a fact
now when you when you lose jobs and then
when you streamline sometimes not all
the time but sometimes the philosophy
does change you started it all for
saying your company did what restructure
it got restructured why they got bought
out thank you in King's defense he is
making some place because some sometimes
companies restructure to make themselves
more attractive for but I'm not saying
Sony's getting better what else I'm just
saying sometimes that happens but back
to my overall play the point is the only
thing I'm concerned about on a corporate
level at a business level breath is that
sometimes philosophies that do change
and my only concern is because let's be
real so he's been killing this
generation they've been destroyed like
everything they've done has come up
roses right so I'm just my only concern
is why necessarily change so much right
at your at your pinnacle it could be the
it could be the greatest move ever it
could position them to be down our
competitive endowment once again and I
get out my speculation could be
unfounded but I always concern myself
when you have someone that's leading in
the fashion that they are to do this
much changing I always I always say hey
I hope this is the right thing I hope
this is the right direction a real quick
I think that a lot of this has to do
with and just my opinion I think that
change we're seeing I think this is a
response to you have some new players in
the Emmys
now we have that a little who's giving
yeah you know we have stadia that's
launching in like a week and a half and
then we have when King was talking just
now with anyone else seeing things an
xbox green or was that just me the name
field ominous Maximus next generation
cuz you brought up the beginning of this
generation right really focused on
Indies
so if Shuhei is going to focus on Indies
does that mean next gens gonna start
this is listen man already been me here
he told you nobody ever wins this is the
second time around you know you don't go
back to back to a cog needles point do
you cannot you can change for the sake
of change when something isn't
necessarily at least outwardly broken
right doesn't make a lot of sense to me
because if you're following in Microsoft
footsteps Microsoft's footsteps and
you're looking at what they're doing is
saying yes I'm reading the tea leaves
this is where we're going
it may work for Microsoft I don't know
really were and we said this before I
don't know that it works for Sony mm-hmm
only Sony has always thrived as a result
of being different than Microsoft mm-hmm
always thrived as a result of being
different than Microsoft what happens
when there's parity in every single
level internet uncle power in terms of
at least output of first party output
and forget about waiting we do know
dreaming there's been established and it
goes back to cogs point is like when you
change philosophy right and it looks
like they're following through with
Microsoft does that suit what some of
these customers and went to Sony because
they're so different
Microsoft hey Kay can I get off for
about yea big soft said um you know I
really think I really think this is a
response to Google coming in and
potentially being a disrupter I know we
joke around about I really I really
think for Sony it's like maybe much more
than maybe not as much as for like
Microsoft but I think I think stadia
coming in and doing what they're doing I
think Sony's like wait a minute we need
to potentially position ourselves to
prohibit if we need to because as the
market shifts and we've seen this we see
this in other industries if there's a
disruptor in an industry if the market
shifts they don't want to be left behind
they want to be able to pivot if they
need to to stay competitive and I think
that's what a lot of this a lot of the
changes that we're seeing potentially
maybe we'll see allows them to do if
that happens and you know cuz there's
new look there's new players in this I
mean Google
apples in this now Amazon's in this
weird what they pivot into into I think
I think you'll probably see them if they
have to see the market shift Streamy
becomes big I think you'll see them
pivot towards more of a similar stadia
maybe as a model and maybe rely less on
hardware man maybe you see them you know
point
I love when they drink the juice and
then the juice turning to green juice -
these dudes jumping out of hardware but
if do it let me see I'm okay if
Microsoft gets out of hardware I'm a
look I'm okay if the barriers to
Hardware broken down right okay if
everything becomes an app and I can game
on the ultimate machine which is the PC
the PC out of it being that you can't
take the peace because you do a lot of
yapping all over the place either
PlayStation game while Microsoft gaming
your PC gamer right now right now can
see that I'm capping from Microsoft even
if you go to my game of pig is me and
Phil so listen I'm not are you gonna say
I'm not gonna stay in this one position
my energy has always stayed the same
all right so I'm not drinking different
types of kool-aid I'm just drinking one
kool-aid all right but you've been
telling me they're going they're doing
this to position yourself in pivot they
so they need to in is where are they
pivoting to the stakes off
yeah Brad now as you say if you know
again stop talking about pivoting uh no
I mean if it becomes a situation where
they need to I mean I where they have to
pivot to streaming or make that
investment I think that's why they're
putting and making these changes like
the partnership with with Microsoft with
the with rely on Microsoft errors cloud
system yeah I don't blame me for that oh
oh absolutely that's that's not that's a
smart thing for them to do they clearly
don't have the infrastructure to do it
so if if they can do with Microsoft why
not also I guess the question let me
jump in make a great point the question
now tying that into our kings asking you
and then tying that into what solve is
asking do we think from a philosophy
stand but that is somewhat adopting
Microsoft philosophy on some level right
so do we are we concern that they may be
changing their DNA their identity which
is the exclusives the you know they're
not being on different platforms and
stuff like that that kind of gave them
that succession or this generation are
you concerned about them losing their
brand identity you know what man I'm for
me the biggest thing is the games if the
games are there I'm okay at the end of
the day to me that's paramount if the
quality of the first party still it oh
that's all I really care about right -
so your whole thing is until you see a
decrease in cop quality with the games
then you have pong sir but until days
then you're fine I do think that's like
look like this amount of leadership
change it might not be concerning but
it's worth talking about talked about
it's come true you can sit there and say
I'm willy-nilly crazy
those dudes gonna get exit out on that
stage you laugh me off I don't see it
happening
y'all are sitting there drinking the
wrong juice
I don't care what's going on conscience
came next is this when your playstation
5 ship it might have an Amazon logo on
all my date they are the only gaming
company it's always brought up with
being purchased they only did not
Microsoft when you're talking about
Microsoft oh they might be out of the
gaming of the space they might not make
a console that has been debunked that
has been put into bushes you know that
has been shown to your face that we're
going hard in this space and we're gonna
win in his space right and I'm not
saying we cuz I'm not gonna nickel from
it but what I'm talking about that's
their mantra going forward Nintendo is
never getting out it's always gonna have
something in your hand it's some weird
form or fashion to yank your wallet and
listen Nintendo doesn't care about power
Nintendo doesn't care about anything but
you spending money and winning every
holiday season which I have won every
MPD's I have bent the knee to that and I
don't care because that's their space we
don't ever see Nintendo getting out of
that space even what they losing with
the game real quick genitive cake equals
the Oracle on Cottenham slowboat
backslash he said yeah I see a decrease
in quality this year he said they went
from guard award Detroit and spider-man
today's gone concrete GD and death
strength so glad your papi asked me is
saying see the writing on the wall he
said it's going down I'm gonna dress him
on Wednesday
the motion is coming
they shot so they hold him back one last
bullet because they know they got just
salivating they told you was coming out
push back into the bushes quality
control because at some point in time
you know the same aim that you would
have got they just don't got any games
to give you oh my god you talked about
Nintendo with the handheld you know kind
of you know space and then you got
PlayStation holding it down with the
console space and doing their thing with
their exclusives and all that it's it's
it seems like the natural way for Xbox
to go where they're going with the
streaming with the play everywhere play
on PC that's their space now it's all
about the services now so I'm with you
on that like that's that's common sense
but it's a great point yeah that's right
well DNA is a company right now anyway
and that's not gonna stop so when people
are saying oh xbox is dead they're not
selling enough consoles I don't think
Microsoft necessarily cares as much as
we do we're still making their money
that division is still profitable I mean
real quick I let me interrupt I do gotta
go that's one of the guys I do want to
give you guys a big shout out to get
into mm yeah no seriously you guys are
one of the best podcasters
congratulations again and Eric oh we got
to connect on Twitter so we can get all
right
regular pistol we gotta talk about III
because I just talked to another person
I'm not gonna talk about it now because
that's gonna be a really huge thing
right now we get into packs credentials
and all that stuff together first and
then we're gonna be moving on to e3 and
I'll be giving you all the particulars
on how everything is gonna move forward
but of course you always got a bit in
our home so I appreciate him and I'm
looking forward to manner like I said I
already told the wife so she knows what
she knows what the deal is let you know
what the deal with one of the biggest
things I really want to go into EXO is
first off what is your it's not
happening moment obviously it's not e3
but I still like to know if you know be
realistic you know my King don't say
they're buying Sony - what what is
something that you think's going to
happen and three who or what fanbase do
you think is gonna enjoy this the most
oh man you want me on this but I haven't
really thought about it what I want to
happen I'm this kind of goes in with I
don't think it's happening and that's
fable I really want to see fable and
what's up with that game and if it's
coming or what like I would I would that
was one of my favorite franchises on 60
so yeah yeah that's it's kind of the
same answer for both like I wanted to
happen but I don't think it's happening
but I don't know I haven't really
thought about it though kind of me on
the spot I mean I'm assuming I'm
assuming it cuz based on the track
record and I
really don't tune in I kind of catch the
foot the footnotes but they've been kind
of disappointing I haven't really been
truly like crazy going hype over
something as far as XO goes and I'm
hoping they just do that for me in some
way like show me something that I can be
hyped about I think they're gonna focus
on that one game right from what's that
with a developer when they just
purchased ninja teri obscene they
showing that Erin Greenberg he posted a
picture and he said in the picture he
said that there was rare that was going
to be there and it said seed thieves
there was a ninja theory they said
bleeding-edge the top one is redacted so
you know we have no clue what that is
but what I thought was interesting is if
city didn't say out of worlds it said
obsidian and I felt like if they put the
gains for the other ones why didn't they
do that with obsidian if it was an outer
world they would have put it outer
worlds there I think they put CDs and
they put bleeding edge yeah I agree I
want to jump around that real quick
because um as you know I'm biggest of
city and fan board but oh yeah like to
be honest I didn't think they would have
any presence and all their and then when
I seen them there I'm like okay they're
gonna be there but they addict said when
you look at the Xbox on the EXO 19 list
you see everybody listed with their
gangs you know ninja Terry who
bleeding-edge everybody obsidians not
listed so it does have me like yo are
they going to announce something is like
slow-mo was saying like there's another
thing that says redacted no and it's not
a game and not a developer so I think we
get some surprise I think we do get
something I'm trying to keep
expectations oh it's the inside Xbox you
well you know I do think they do have at
least one or two surprises and hopefully
one is a new IP there's something new
that they could talk about something to
get excited I think for me I think maybe
one more studio acquisition whatever the
case maybe something small I mean
again I have no idea what it could be
but one more studio acquisition just to
sort of just ice the cake a little bit
and then I mean in terms of other stuff
I'd like to see something cool like a
extruder rage for launching in game past
or something like oh I think that's a
definite thing the fact that they they
got the tempo determine what their yeah
I remember I shout out help me at least
out there the PAX I had that interview
yes we know that that would be a good
backing from Microsoft to put that in
game pass to get them that exposure and
green yeah that was a budget and it's
out today and it's out yeah that that's
a passion project for those deaths they
got the approval from Sega to do that so
it makes sense the dots connect saw by
which you're now you know obviously a
lot of I want to ask you guys there's a
lot of going on about huge rumors about
acquisitions first off I want to ask the
chat what's the acquisition that you
think that's realistic and what do you
guys think that they might buy if there
is a studio that spawn that EXO because
Matt booty and Phil's prints are gonna
be there I have a feeling that they're
going to announce that something if you
got booty and they're actually flying
media out to just Gordon I mean he's one
of us he was like normally with the
exomes we like you know maybe one or two
people they fly if they're flying out
this many people they have clearly
something huge saying you're not gonna
bring all these people out so that's why
I do think this is different
normally I'm very down as I said extra
box but I think this is very differently
gonna be something supposedly maybe
shattering the console maybe the actual
name of the console just keep that since
you have the PS 5 out there already you
know maybe but you don't think they
saved that for like the UM you know you
like that February March reveal where
they just talked about a console and I
think
get in there yeah true but at the same
time I guess just a name you just drop
the name and people be like oh whatever
you know it you could just drop it you
don't have to you more you don't have to
stay much more but that doesn't very
interesting I would say this though
another thing to look out for is maybe
it give more concrete sort of
information about when game past proper
launches maybe open it up to more people
I'm not I'm sorry x5 when maybe open it
up to more people and I'll be honest - I
think you gotta look out for wasteland 3
and in exact yeah right Microsoft right
now is riding a high of these Western
RPGs like obviously the outer world is
big and I think in exile is gonna
benefit from that and I think everything
that I've seen from from wasteland 3 it
seems like it's another one of those
that's absolutely fantastic people might
be turned off by the isometric stuff but
just the fact that they're riding this
high of like quality Western RPGs
couldn't whoa really well for that game
so whoa we do have to our super chef
from jmo Scarlett says was Sony
announced something to kill their
thunder what could they announce it this
morning
the release date would you would you
possibility okay I'm privy to know how
many people is gonna be there who they
called out there right so in knowing
this out of the realm of possibility
they show five new IPs right being that
I know exactly five Studios that's going
to be there that they already acquired
so they show some work from those five I
and those Studios to get y'all lathered
up
[Music]
I do believe that they're gonna show you
two News studio acquisitions because if
you're going into a service model type
of thing you're trying to actually load
your bullets in your chamber more
studios and I believe they will probably
like to release a new game per month
even if it's small every every four four
to five months triple-a title in the
title type of indie titles day and date
once a month in the space of the the
triple a five month cycle so that can
keep getting passed continually growing
and showing you its value so I believe
that they're going to show at least two
new studios acquisitions now any
information on the console I'm with it
in line with sovereign I think they will
give you the name this is the first time
that it's in London right and talking
about the fan fest is the first time is
the fan fest is in London and they have
yeah yeah yeah they've been selling
tickets to this one so at the charge
they kind of changed the way fan fest
was working whereas you you purchase
tickets in a sense and it was telling
that it was still up today I was like
man I might take a flight out there too
it's cool
you shot the Lord Josh writing loads of
gaming that net he will be out there on
the scene y'all we're gonna get you that
coverage that's right so I believe for
the fan fest crowd for the first there
and the huge reception and a coronation
that they're trying to do because it's
weird the level of press that they're
bringing in and the people that they
have glued to this day but they may make
it a big thing about that so I'm gonna
email about it I was like what like am I
gonna show up no
but you gonna send me flight tickets
I'll be out there um but I think it's
something huge so it might be the name
like Sabra said I think he hit on that
um I think it's to studio acquisitions
and I think those five studios they're
going to show you a piece a snippet of
gameplay
so from these studios that they've
purchased because remember everybody's
talking about you've been purchasing but
you haven't been showing so I believe
it's time to flash your hand get you
lathered up and ready for the next
situation going all right I can't wait
till we do il feel that's all I got I
think it's gonna be a bigger show than
normal I do think we're gonna get a
release date for the weight waistline
three I think we're going to get an
unannounced title because if you notice
the way that they they had that lined up
is those that that's posts that's after
the inside Xbox so whatever that is it's
it's relatively close and they're
showing more gameplay after they've
revealed it on stage I think it's
interesting that obsidian is named
they're not the game so maybe of
something maybe it could be something
simple because it'd be something small
we don't know I kind of feel like they
have enough studios at this point where
they can start releasing you know some
of their stuff at stuff like EXO I think
they're gonna announce some studio
acquisitions and for all we know it
could be like a bleeding edge thing that
redacted
yes sorry that redact it could just be a
game that they just bought in their next
game is gonna be on their platforms just
like bleeding edge they bought a ninja
theory and then the next year bleeding
edge is announced on their platform so
that could be exactly the same thing
they bought something in the past six
months and that the game that they were
working on is is going to be shown on
the floor so also cuz I see the 24
titles here and I think that's what it's
gonna be so yeah I hate to be negative
I don't think it's gonna be anything I
think the biggest news is gonna be the
acquisitions and maybe that had acted
because Aaron Greenberg was very proud
of that redacted who knows what could be
could be lucky tails - we don't know you
know highly I actually wouldn't mind a
record - if they could make it better
the first one was kind of rough actually
I got no problem playing The Witcher 540
P but you know the raid core is out of
the question just because if it is even
though I am NOT a fan of recoil if it is
announced it was very boring but I will
say this I will say I've always
criticized - Alex Point avoids criticize
from white Microsoft for the one and
done the burger shaker fries and if they
stuck to a franchise that they owned and
made it better I will bend in me and say
you know what you was on to something
because at no point in time should they
just be doing this one and dusted with
so many high that they put out there and
they just let flounder and the bushes
under certain regimes that we shall not
mention his name again taint another
company oh yeah bro I'm so happy that we
in a different wavelength right now on
energy is different so let's keep up
with that same energy I just hope they
don't announce it on
I just was spicy today we show no what
if they show actual headed quit it
getting play like boombastic stuff like
so tell me we three but like four but
Slater that got it for XO yeah for the
next generation you know I highly doubt
scarlet anything like if I were to give
a percentage of something scarlet
related in Excel it would be like Halo 5
percent oh damn I think we got X cloud
oh I always have high expectations in
everything that I do I don't ever go in
with a base where I will be all except
this I don't ever do that field I go in
with high expectations I mean cuz you
know the big chad is coming for me and I
do so if you think I'm gonna be
disappointed when they do do it no I'm
not because I understand the business
i'ma shoot my shot high so they don't
hit that if they hit this let's let's
take into account that if they hit a
shot I might not be here next week would
be crazy talk about XO 2019 I guess
we'll do with the closing poll
unfortunately some reason the poker
disappeared but I remember what it is
you guys so the poll is you know with XO
coming up what do you think of the fan
base of these respected Studios that
they they've announced I'm not gonna say
like thirty four thirty or something cuz
we don't know if they're gonna be there
what fan base you think's could be the
most impressed or the most pleased is it
going to be a obsidian be ninja theory
hey rare or D minecraft I was gonna have
your oh oh oh hold on I gotta get this
super jet shot the element appeal with
the finalists which a fantasy land
prediction Shawn Layden shows up on
stage
[Laughter]
that's the redacted that's the retention
oh I'm so sorry which I will never ever
I wanted to say some off the wall for
the D but I was like I gotta get my
craft is big I have to give there's a
lot of Minecraft fans I was leaving
literally gonna leave minecraft out and
put something you know kognito famous
last choice is completely crazy but I
gotta give my craft they shine so you
know I gave so there it is you know the
poll will be up I don't even know I'm
playing world right now something I
would have never purchased ever oh here
we go
Erica for the win I see there's people
in the shadow that appreciate your input
on stuff yeah I appreciate that I got
some love and achai appreciate you guys
and to you i LP it Congrats again on the
30k that's awesome I hope you guys keeps
growing where can everyone find me well
era cuts for the win is my name across
everything so twitch Twitter YouTube all
my gamer tags and all of that you guys
exactly our name checking out yeah yeah
so you can find me there I've been
screaming death stranding so if you want
to watch me you know carry
packages and crack some jokes about it
I'll be doing that I had a good time I
always do with you guys it's great show
and I always end up laughing for sure so
yeah I appreciate the invite and yeah
you guys I'll see you whenever I see you
of course of course a little late Erika
always a pleasure and I glad you came on
because they wanted to let you know I
saw your tweet earlier this weekend you
are loved going on but everybody really
appreciates you see everybody with this
statue he meant spinning yes Skeletor
that's how I look next week if he's
bright I'm right I'm gonna come in here
ponch the TV screen on the scream I got
the power loads a game net where we have
a ton of opinion pieces and stuff like
that going on there which he made up the
inscription right now thank you so much
I would like to really check out the
website because it's a different take on
a lot of things you know you can go on
is um a menage of different of flavors
that's there like you got combat talk
you have statues and you have our Lord
Cognito and Yvonne says you have with
with the last word
you have opinion pieces that are up you
have our gaming reviews but attic you
have the team stuff that's there
listen um it's growing and it's growing
into a different space and you as you're
watching it you're watching it mature
into a different thing and that's all
through you guys right so I don't tell
you to go to the site because I don't go
there I actually go to not read articles
and I'm like wow I didn't even know that
we had this guy here doing this stuff
and one of my favorite guys to do
reviews is de la Pole so any time as
reviews I'm always all over or MJ the
boss
reviews his scary games is the greatest
I really love to watch that stuff so I'm
pretty sure that you'll find something
they're also going to damn it I mean you
could tweet out sorry we you know we
ended we bang so we can finish get the
announcement self then a complete once
again for the banhammer doing what he
does the winner are gleen pokemon sword
or shield giveaway at the hosing HP
congratulations Lord Jose oh yeah and
find out which version of the game you
want things apart in the iron Lords
podcasts we really amused Ozma - yeah
better real quick I don't know where we
at with the show this is one continuous
thing or it's a separate episode shout
out the YouTube just messing us up but
it's so good on real quick man so we got
some announcers obviously like King said
Lords of game and dotnet is moving and
grooving thank Lady Erica for getting us
Hector Rainey who's been fantastic for
us all he tremendous oh shelter and then
we got some requisition
we had a undead dxv I holding down on
the editing tip as well and then of
course some new acquisitions this week
the multi-verse invasion you know my boy
Mike P the truth
downloads gave me that net with some
great opinion pieces and armed spicy
takes always always good as course an
avid Madden player so please check him
out he will be getting the ball rolling
and of course one in particular long
awaited acquisition the anchorman v2 is
in the building
so salute Eggar bear he will be joining
us as well absolutely he will be helping
us out various things man and he also
will be giving those hot fresh but
fenced it takes as he does you already
know yes a salute leg of v2 so more
surprises more things come in more
giveaways 2020 is looking to be very
special for modes of give me that net so
please follow us there and yeah man I
want to salute the writing and of course
follow the at Lords gaming net
Twitter account there you can find those
great pieces and a lot of these people
putting in fantastic work so that's all
I got just want to get that off real
quick where can people find Lords
sovereign at the one that ignores my
party invites P as well as being
sovereign on PS and Xbox Live where
you'd normally in fact right way I don't
see your party invites you get the ghost
him cuz he has ghosted me on this game
that I've been trying to finish forever
and he got the key I'm mad as hell
exactly do you find me reluctantly
delivering packages and distracting the
rest of people describe this game and I
just get a kick out of it but you know
anyway so you know first off you can
find me Lord at it pretty much through
everything now I'm on xbox I'm Lord
attics
[Applause]
I'll pee YouTube unfortunately its
gaming addict on there what's not
unfortunately you know one thing I want
to say is you know we have like a
hundred and forty five yes watch it
fine you guys come every week and
support us live you know we appreciate
all the super chests we appreciate the
likes that you give us we're ly 9 away
from 100 before the end of the podcast
you know hit that like button a few guys
don't mind yes we cannot begin to
describe to you how how you know
appreciated we are of you know the
support you give us every week every
week it seems like more and more people
show up you know and we'll be back next
week and until next time yeah somebody
better hope Microsoft didn't do what I
said